Tony Beshara runs a recruitment company in Dallas and has been finding jobs for people since 1973.
In his book, Acing the Interview, he supplies job seekers with honest and forthright information...
...for answering even the most difficult interview questions.
This book is a useful guide for people looking for work because it takes the reader...
...through the whole process from a first interview to evaluating and analyzing a job offer.
How do you deal with the fact that you were fired from your last job...
...or that you only spent a very short time in your previous jobs?
How do you make a new employer believe that you will stay?
Perhaps, you work for a great company, but you just don't like your job.
How do you explain why you want to leave?
There are over 450 typical interview questions.
He also explains questions you should ask of your prospective employer prior to accepting a job.